[Music]
hi everyone Seth McFarland here and I am
thrilled to share the trailer for our
new peacock original series Ted telling
the story of Ted and John's early days
let's take a
look hey
Johnny how bad is school going to suck
you're not going to like it how bad well
it's like getting your nuts smashed
together so hard they become just one
nut holy
[__] you should be going to school every
day with John know you might have fun no
I would not have fun I gu the house when
you guys are
out what happened to the TV it was an
accident you're going to school and
you're going to grow a [__] brain oh
come
on hey you're bringing your dolls to
school it's the '90s times are
changing sexual education let's start
with masturbation if you're going to
assign homework Johnny already did it
this morning shut the [__] up
dude I haven't smoked I haven't had sex
I haven't had a girlfriend I'm going to
lose it you and me have been best
friends like our whole lives we're about
to get high for the first time can we
have drugs please let's do this
[Music]
right oh
man can you guys believe we're like
having an experience and experience in
reality is there a [__] gas leak or
something nice costume F face possible
that the two of you might not be total
screw
up take a long look this is what life
is [__] Teddy from the last virgin in
school we can fix this we got to find a
fire fresh penis get your fresh penis
here Jesus Christ still has that new
penis smell you shut up all right I'm
just trying to
[Music]
help
he